they pulled me out can you hear me no
they cannot why not because the code you
just uploaded wasn't actually my portal
dent formula it was a virus giving me
full control over the brain Eliezer what
are you talking about this is a memory
you can't alter details of a memory true
but you can alter anything you want
about a totally fabricated origin story
it's a trap abort I'm feeling as
Shoney's repeat we never left this Shoni
mission accomplished boys pull me out
Roger that another day another dollar my
greatest creature Erwin gratulations
agent you'll be highly commended for
this always wait for permission to feel
accomplishment that's my motto
exes me why would Rick Sanchez turn
himself in well I'm just a dumbass bug
but it's possible Rick knew he'd be
interrogated to this facility where we
not only keep our most wanted but our
most sensitive data anyone here with
level nine access could pose and I don't
know collapse the government I'm just
going to go take a dump is it cool if I
use the level 9 bathrooms what's the
level 9 master access code again oh it's
easy
8/3
hi Rick bye Rick sir Rick t99 is
returning from the mission alone
apparently sealed team Rick suffered
heavy casualties
bring him in he says he'll only talk to
a Rick with higher clearance
la-dee-da give me that p99 this is the
commander in chief of the Citadel good
good enough he's just fine blow him up
I'm gonna go take a [ __ ] hey well what
what are you doing in here this area is
for teleporting the entire Citadel to
somewhere else using only buttons and
dials
yeah well that idea to have it design
that way then isn't it
[Music]
take a chin along until it finish what I
started that is how you get level 9
access without a password
hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Rick and Morty episode 1 video
I'll explain everything that's going on
in when it's coming back they implied
that they're going to replay the episode
in the future if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything
I'll be doing Rick and Morty videos when
the season gets here and leave all your
requests for bonus videos in the
comments below till we get there so the
episode was titled the Rick shank Rick
Dempsey and just a twist on Shawshank
Redemption great surprise cameo from
Nathan Fillion it'll be fun to see which
other stars pop up during the season
when he jumps into Nathan's ilion's mind
he says comedy comes in threes he says
he needs to take a [ __ ] three times
during the episode leaving you with my
fear wicker furniture my desire to play
the trumpet my tentative plans to
purchase a hat six years of improv
workshops comedy comes in three I'm just
gonna go take a dump is it cool if I use
the level 9 bathroom he's just five blow
them up I'm gonna go take a [ __ ] at the
end of that movie careful spoiler alert
for Shawshank Redemption so the main
character at the end of that movie
escapes prison by crawling out through a
sewer it's disgusting so in this episode
rick escapes galactic prison by crawling
through the minds the sewer of various
galactic empire and other council of
rick members till he achieves his goal
of destroying toppling the galactic
government by surprise surprise
just devaluing their currency it is a
haunting real-world conspiracy theory
ending to the episode and totally
appropriate all you have to do to topple
a nation is just devalue their currency
none of the [ __ ] and the government
will work for you if you don't pay them
so that is how rick defeats the
government so they are not the main
threat now although back up big spoiler
for the end of the episode we know that
birdperson has returned one of the best
moments ever online now do it
I am Phoenix person Phoenix person is
that what we settled on I thought we all
agreed on cyber bird you said you didn't
care what he was called as long as we
brought him back yeah but Phoenix person
find it who cares so Tammy in the
remnant of the Galactic government have
resurrected bird person Terminator style
and now it looks like he is going to be
one of Rick's biggest enemies in
addition to Morty so there was a runner
in the episode where he starts
describing Rick is a sort of sick
twisted God not a hero like summer
believes him to be he's trying to
disavow her of that idea he even takes
her back to Cronenberg universe to try
and prove his point this is what Rick
leaves in his wake he even legitimately
tries to kill him during the episode not
understanding Rick's twist so while I
don't think he's completely on the path
to becoming a version of evil Morty I do
think that opening the door for people
within Rick circle to start going
against him like he'll be fighting
against birdperson presumably his former
best friend is now being twisted by the
Galactic government but summer was great
in this episode I love how she goes
really crazy with the flies then later
they pay it off when Rick comes back in
turns in the right way it is a secret
code what are you what are you doing
grandfather must have some secret lab
right with like laser guns and jetpacks
and a space tank and we could go break
him out of prison
look at these dead flies maybe if we
arrange them in a certain order it plays
the hologram tore it open to see her
door summer you're freaking me out
what's the not cool Jerry man's garage
is his castle
[Music]
so they're hyping up a whole bunch of
stuff here and then we got to talk about
jerry i was so happy with the end of the
episode of course Beth is going to
choose Rick over Jerry so I don't think
Jerry's off the show or anything he's
one of their most important punching
bags so I'm expecting him to come back
in some awkward way but we'll see how
long him staying away from the family
sticks because Rick is like I am now the
de facto leader of this family and if
you didn't catch it to mcnugget dipping
sauce was an actual thing it was a
promotion for the movie Mulan back in
1998 in 1998 they had this promotion for
the Disney film Mulan where they were
they they created a new sauce for the
McNuggets called Szechuan sauce and it's
delicious and then they got rid of it
and now it's gone it's the only place
we're going to be able to try it it's in
my memory Rick you're doing this bit
while your brain is melting okay all
right all right
so the Rick and Morty people were like
slowly trying to bring that back like
it's a way of saying that Dan Harmon the
people that write the show that make the
show were huge fans of that really
wanted to come back so they were trying
to bait McDonald's hey want to get in on
this this is the original commercial for
that okay when I sit him down with
chicken oh my I know it's a goner this
is normal on the epic adventure about
this cool girl the same time McDonald's
is often tender crispy pig McNuggets and
a new Szechuan sauce tastes of the eat
the Easter egg in there is great too
very says nine more seasons Rick and
Morty forever so I know that sort of a
play on the community six seasons in a
movie but they did up their episode
count for season three over season two
in season one so if you have any friends
that aren't watching the show yet be
sure to introduce them this is one of
those shows that builds audience as it
goes along usually it's the other way
around but as he explains during the
episode the origin story is completely
fabricated so we still don't know what
the true origin story of Rick is but I
do like the version they put forth in
this c-137 rick is twisted by a more
evil version of himself into becoming
the Rick we see today the Rick is trick
of them all for those of you freaking
out that they might not replay the
episode this tweet from their official
account implies that they'll continue to
rerun the episode
till the rest of the series drops this
summer now they didn't say May they
didn't say June they just said summer so
what
probably get a better idea when we get
closer great April Fool's joke but
typically it's a Sunday night show so
depending on what kind of Rick and Morty
videos you guys want me to make I'll do
stuff like this the night that it airs
and then I'll do longer videos the next
day so it'll be during the summer Game
of Thrones is happening during the
summer so by June Rick and Morty and
Game of Thrones will just dominate
everything that we're talking about
believe all your requests for bonus
videos in the comments below
we got the Walking Dead finale tonight
while you wait for that to post click
here for more Rick and Morty season 3
and click here for new Game of Thrones
thank you so much for watching let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video
[Music]
[Applause]